Pete Davidson has a special on Netflix
come out right in he was hard on louis
c.k guys it's pretty interesting yeah he
legit reason to I can tell you I'm not
give away the joke but he sat down with
Charlemagne who does these one-on-one
interviews they're fantastic it's on
YouTube and he was talking about Pete
Davidson by like you know he dates the
hottest chicks or everything cuz the hot
chicks has a huge dick huge dick you
know that no he's the originator of big
dick energy ariana grande started that
with Pete as a huge [ __ ] and he's on
satellite live and all that but he
suffers from horrible the horrible
depression dude awful depression touch
reality cuts himself and also Jesus
Christ
yeah and how he's got those giant bags
under his eyes he's the nicest guy
though man I mean he's been nicest
[ __ ] guy huh and everybody hates on
like I wonder why why would you hate it
just gets a ton of chicks yes because he
[ __ ] all these really famous chicks I
think that has something to do with it
and then I think it's probably a group
of people who love ariana grande my kind
of crazy it might afford that no but he
without even trying makes news and so
people they said and he was like man I
tried he's like I swore me ass Stan I'm
due Saturday live he's like don't say
live in I get what he's saying he goes
on Senate live he's like I just say
something to the writing room cuz they
always made me have to be that like the
dumb guy so in every bit I was the dumb
guy he's a cop see I'm not a dumb person
but they made it to me like this he goes
and I've gone on the road you stand well
nobody wants to pay to see a dumbass
like you no one's gonna pay to see a
dummy so it's actually hurting me you
decide to go in the writing room like
you know I couldn't sound jzuk I can't
be the dumbass of every scene every now
and then it's fine but I can't just be
the dummy and everything yeah so you
know he's obviously he's having a hard
time a lot of times he doesn't he was a
comedian phenom dude he was like 17 yeah
doing legit stand-up and like the
selarón [ __ ] and then open for Chappelle
and just be struggling out when he is I
think yeah he's not wiling out he he
talks about I've always liked him and
but he's super nice to me
I love Pete Davidson but talks about
yeah he has a bit out of it but it
it's up a special how when he was on
Saturday Night Live Lucy Kay was on
there and you know Peter smokes a lot of
weed cuz instead of taking prescription
medications weed helps him calm down and
not be so crazy right so he's a big
update for weed
so he was smoking weed you know on the
set you know that's way does but when
Michael smokes weed but not as much as
him he was saying so he was getting high
and that's when louis c.k was hosting so
he says he gets off the elevator louis
ck's like holding court with all the the
cast members and pete just like waves
and lisa came for him is like how
[ __ ] high that kid look how high Pete
Davidson like this [ __ ] kid he was so
goddamn high man smoke in his life away
and Pete said he was so heizak that
didn't happen that's that's not real
that's in whatever it gets on the
elevator next day he gets a call from
Lorne Michaels office he was which is
weird cuz I've been here for how many
six years yes they've never once called
me so that I'll [ __ ] here we got me get
fired things didn't get fired every week
right he goes up there and more my
cleaners hey once you know Lucy cake in
my office yesterday and asked me to fire
you
I let you go and Lorne Michaels like not
happening like smoke weed but maybe just
don't do it as much in front of the
guest stuff like that but do your thing
it's what makes you you and so PJ is
like what the [ __ ] man say he was just a
dick to all young comics he's ever met
Lucy Kate's been you know what's going
on he's gonna dick his entire life so
he's I'm not I'm like anyway that's the
premises this joke is yours so then I
wake up one morning
it's about Louie CK Jack on front of
women I should go yes
and he goes on this bit but you know
what if you talk to any young comics it
Louie CK is known for that yeah I'm not
telling anything you don't know special
new you I'm not saying there's a reason
why a lot of people like oh wow
well Louie from my experience i don't
know him Louie was never a very warm guy
that's one of the issues seem very
generous yeah when that stuff came out
that was one of the issues is he was
just an [ __ ] to everybody that was
one of the issues yeah everyone's like a
[ __ ] that yeah LEM fry you know you're
fired he was not known in comedy circles
for exposing himself is not true
enforcing lesser-known communities to
watch a mess it's not true
that's is when people start [ __ ]
things up with nobody it wasn't known it
in fact the I'm gonna say I've been in
this business a long time
Lulu seek a jacket off yeah it wasn't
really known that that wasn't until
things started coming out and then that
story came out that there was one story
I know the guy I did I know a lot about
it
it did these these things get a little
crazy but but I will say that my
experience is you call it right away
that yeah yeah I think when you're an
older nice man when you're an old
economic and you're established it's
upon you to make it easier on younger
comics and be cool hmm and be generous
hmm and it means the world to young
Tommy it does and I both I've seen a lot
of comics through the years who would
got up and bump everybody because they
do two hours not these days though is
that everyone get away with anymore I
not be the store if you tried that
you know if it's bad leaving a bump well
just say like let's say someone came and
bought me like in about me I'm the new
guy right yeah they buy me I went to you
I was like hey dude blank
X comic bought me you and rogue in or
whoever crit whoever like they did what
yeah well that's not what we do around
now and you say and take me out of it
because I'm their friend but anybody it
used to be like scuse me bump yeah I
never did that ever you know yeah I mean
yeah everyone's so nice like last night
I was sitting before I got my set and
Bobby comes up goes hey you know you
belong here yeah you know you belong
here yeah these jobs in my head up in
value that's really cool mmm-hmm good
for Bobby that [ __ ] um
he looked [ __ ] sweet to you took his
glasses off but he of these [ __ ] so
this sweet outfit on yeah okay he's got
a podcast with Santino now yeah they do
it's great I love it yeah I want to hear
it but it's they uh they got put twins
off see from the movie twins people that
go but that's racist cuz your agent no
you [ __ ] idiots are all sports singer
Danny DeVito
look at my eyes smaller smaller
I know you know I mean I know because I
tired body I am buddy call just call
because I am body the way hold on so how
is this it's spelled just kung fu kung
foo yeah you're saying golf well that's
how it's said so as I'm from I studied
in China pistol